[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti ea tutte le grazie di
essere qui questa sera io sono giulia
pasquini e la mia collega idea clementi
a causa di forze maggiori non ha potuto
essere qui ma so che ci ha preparato una
bella sorpresa che vedremo fra poco
lei che vedete qui accanto a me ha
appetiti e tutte e tre siamo interpreti
e performer della lingua dei segni
quando io e giulia abbiamo cominciato a
pensare a che tipo di intervento
volevamo portare qui su una cosa ci
siamo subito trovati d'accordo
non volevamo proporvi la lezione di
lingua dei segni
ma in realtà il mio obiettivo questa
sera è sardi delle pillole una curiosità
che magari ci piacerebbe portaste con
voi come motivo di riflessione
io ho parlato proprio nel tema del
cambiamento per la lingua dei segni e
non di là del linguaggio dei segni
ora spiegare questa differenza reterebbe
veramente il mio intervento troppo lungo
troppo tecnico e forse anche un pelino
noioso e però è importante che
ricordiate che si parla di lingua dei
segni e non lingua dei gesti perché la
lingua dei segni si muove su un canale
visivo gestuale per cui si ascolta con
gli occhi e le mani il corpo e le
espressioni facciali diventano i veri
protagonisti della comunicazione proprio
nel tema del cambiamento
proviamo a fare un bel passo indietro ea
immaginare come
una persona sorda potesse relazionarsi
io risolvere una serie di incombenze
quotidiane
prima dell'avvento del cellulare
c'era un particolare dispositivo
telefonico chiamato dts
provate a immaginare una sorta di
macchina da scrivere un piccolo display
con quella persona sorda per iscritto
inviava la sua esigenza ad un tecnico
operatore che era dall'altra parte del
dispositivo che munito di una cornetta
provava a risolvere le esigenze del
momento
un appuntamento da un medico da un
avvocato o alla posta o un qualsiasi
ufficio pubblico risolvere esigenze
quotidiane
ecco questo era lo strumento principale
utilizzato poi con il tempo e
l'avanzamento della tecnologia sia
arrivato al nostro moderno cellulare
ecco la tecnologia ha portato notevoli
vantaggi un po a tutti anche i sordi
innanzitutto perché ha rafforzato la
loro autonomia
provate a la cosa più banale pensare
all'uso della videochiamata periodo di
questo di lockdown che abbiamo vissuto
in realtà ognuno di noi
sicuramente sarà capitato almeno una
volta di fare una videochiamata
ecco l'uso della videochiamata non solo
va a rafforzare l'autonomia ma in realtà
permette una comunicazione più veloce
che in passato era impensabile non solo
la comunicazione più veloce ma è anche
diretta e immediata istantanea e
la videochiamata e visiva come la lingua
dei segni
ecco perché diventa lo strumento
principale poi un altro grande
cambiamento è l'uso e l'avvento dei
social
ora i social network hanno modificato
profondamente il modo di relazionarci
con l'altro i social network più banali
facebook o instagram hanno portato anche
non solo rafforzare l'autonomia della
persona sorda ma anche includerlo a
pieno titolo in maniera attiva alla vita
sociale e avere informazioni in tempo
reale e soprattutto all'inizio infatti
dell'emergenza sanitaria le informazioni
sui vari protocolli da seguire sanitari
ma sono passati in realtà proprio
tramite social è un'altra
un altro punto fondamentale è stato che
l'avvento dei social permette alle
persone sorde poco ma noi di conoscere
altre comunità sorte quindi italiani o
stranieri e questo porta uno scambio uno
scambio che diventa scambio culturale
uno scambio che porta crescita
collaborazione e confronto
io ho detto di essere come le mie
colleghe un interprete e un performer di
lingua dei segni
ecco qui ci troviamo proprio nel bel
mezzo del cambiamento cosa fa il
performer della lingua dei segni si
occupa di tutta quella sfera artistica
quindi danza musica teatro e interpreta
e traduce in lingua dei segni brani
musicali opere teatrali e questo sta
portando e ha portato una maggiore
sensibilizzazione al pubblico udente
rendendo quindi la lingua dei segni
sempre più una normalità e non più un
eccezione proprio nel tema del
cambiamento io ho anche detto di parlare
di lingua dei segni e non lingua dei
gesti
ora noi italiani siamo famosissimi in
tutto il mondo per avere questa spiccata
gestualità mentre si parla e fa parte
della nostra cultura e il nostro dna
però in realtà gesto e segno hanno una
grande differenza perché il gesto non ha
l'esigenza si è legato al contesto ma
non ha l'esigenza di seguire una
struttura linguistica serve in realtà
per dare enfasi per prodotto in maniera
casuale come sto facendo io in realtà
mentre la mia collega e il segno per
essere riconosciuto tale deve avere una
struttura grammaticale e sintattica ed
espressiva
in realtà però adesso vorrei lasciare la
parola alla mia collega giulia clementi
che si potrà dare delle pillole molto
interessanti e molto curiose e proprio
su questo argomento
noi famosissimi nel mondo per parlare a
gesticolare in modo animato
credo che uno tra i gessi più
riconosciuti a livello internazionale
questo ma c'è da fare una
differenziazione tra gesto e segno
potremmo iniziare con un esempio e melli
riallaccia il discorso che ha fatto
giocatore tecnologia
partiamo dal gesto telefono
universalmente tutti quanti nel mondo
potrebbe utilizzare telefono ci sentiamo
di telefono telefono invece le persone
sorde si utilizzano anche telefono ma
nel corso del tempo hanno modificato
questo gesto insegno come per esempio il
vecchio telefono utilizzavano telefono
poi telefono poi diventano telefono
frezza telefono telefono come lo
smartphone che lo teniamo in mano così
finendo al telefono touch
ecco questo è il segno partendo dal
gesto la lingua dei segni è una lingua
veramente veramente ricca e si dimostra
in queste piccole cose no oppure le
parolacce per esempio no non è proprio
l'ambito più adatto per parlarne però si
pensa che il mandare ha promesso una
persona sia universale no col dito medio
per carità non ci sarebbero
fraintendimenti e capiamoci l'intento
comunicativo è molto chiaro ma in lingua
dei segni
anche le parolacce cambiano perché hanno
dei segni collegati con la loro cultura
perché c'è una cultura sorda e questo mi
preme molto sottolinearlo una cultura
sorda che per esempio ecco ve la spiego
in breve qualora dovessi dire la parola
ascoltare che gesto mi fa venire in
mente effettivamente con le mani voi che
cosa fareste ascoltare ascoltare
ascoltare perfetto in lingua dei segni
ci sono anche questi segni ma le persone
sorde ascoltano attraverso un canale
visivo gestuale quindi l'ascolto basterà
attraverso la mista ed ascoltare questa
è la ricchezza e la ricchezza che
entusiasma che fa della lis una vera e
propria lingua
oppure durante le regate spesso noi
utenti che cosa facciamo vantaggioso più
sta a sentire quindi magari faccio coppa
papà è loro che cosa faranno ora lo
sapete perché ve lo ha anticipato prima
useranno la vista quindi che significa
guarda avuto gli occhi indietro
attenzione perché alcuni segni lis non
hanno un vero riscontro in italiano e
quindi anche la traduzione che vi faccio
viso della strana oppure i miff e
rompere gli occhi oppure il mio
preferito perché trovo sia veramente di
un pacifista che questo semplicemente
cosa che noi non possiamo fare perché
pure sentiamo la vecchia e continuiamo a
sentire la persona che urla
loro invece tranquillamente dovremmo
imparare da loro
ecco è questa è una differenza culturale
no tra noi e loro
oppure ecco la lingua dei segni per dire
impossibile utilizza tre diversi segni a
seconda dell'intensità comunicativa che
delle volte non la facciamo trapelare
anche dal tono di voce no quando
dobbiamo distinguere i tre modi di dire
che per noi è impossibile motoria mo la
voce mentre loro hanno dei segni vi
faccio un esempio carico per me è
impossibile che anche per me non ce la
posso faccio papa oppure ma che stai a
dì montato impossibile oppure il terzo
guardi è proprio impossibile
tecnicamente impossibile
mi piace tanto e rita capire quanto il
segno sia collegato non solo con un
intento comunicativo ma anche con un
grado di comunicazione diversa è
veramente meraviglioso a e ci tengo a
sottolineare che la lingua dei segni
cambiano da paese a paese non c'è sì c'è
una lingua dei segni internazionale che
si è studiata può essere mezzo
comunicativo uguale per tutti ma ogni
paese alla propria lingua dei segni
perché la lingua dei segni è
strettamente collegata al territorio e
all'ambiente socio culturale dove si
nasce e attenzione quest'anno me
l'aspettavate ma ci sono anche i
dialetti quindi spesso e volentieri dal
nord al sud
lo stesso segno subisce delle variazioni
bene e vorrei darmi tantissimi esempi ma
il tempo è poco però un'altra un polo
per esempio se vi dicessi la parola più
che buono sono sicura che voi
utilizzereste il gesto buono questo è
corretto e di ha usato anche in lingua
dei segni ma solamente per le pietanze
alimentari perché una persona buona sarà
buona e quindi ecco la differenziazione
tra gesto che può essere anche usato
come segno ma la valenza linguistica di
questo è molto forte perché viene
d'istinto mentre noi invece diciamo
buone cibo può nella persona capire qual
è la loro ricchezza oppure menetrey
mente tantissimi ma il tempo è quello
che purtroppo è quindi iniziamo a
parlare della giornata della medaglia di
quella po meno ricca un po più triste
l'italia è l'unico paese dell'unione
europea non avere ancora riconosce
per lingua dei segni fino all'anno
scorso insieme a noi il primato o se lo
batteva lussemburgo ma stranamente ha
fatto rimango di noi che quindi noi
restiamo l'ultimo paese a non aver
aderito alla convenzione onu del 2006
che ratificava il diritto di
comunicazione delle persone disabili
detto ciò che cosa succede che da questo
grave inadempimento ne seguono una serie
di servizi che fanno sì che la qualità
della vita di una persona sorda in
italia non sia così soddisfacente perché
manca l'accessibilità l'integrazione e
l'inclusione sociale e durante il
periodo dell'emergenza o rid tutti
quanti abbiamo visto come sia facile
mettere un interprete affiancata a conte
oppure al bollettino della protezione
civile e perché no anche un'altra
versione bava se invece no però per noi
questa è stata una presenza
straordinaria per un'emergenza
straordinaria
beh questo dev'essere il mondo che
quotidianità e normalità capire la
differenza e capire anche il sentimento
di rabbia che possono avere queste
persone quando gli viene impiegata una
cosa che invece è così semplice
però voglio dirvi anche una bella cosa
che è successa quest'anno perché è
giusto di verne cari ma anche esaltare
quelli positivi la pubblica utilità per
la prima volta grazie a un progetto di
laura santarelli ha realizzato il primo
sanremo accessibile lingua dei segni e
auto e descrizioni per sordi e per
ciechi quindi capire che le cose belle
si stanno e questo primo passo verso
un'integrazione un'inclusione culturale
importantissimo e la rai lo ha capito e
quindi grazie a una scuola di
performance rock we anche
come la sua collega talia che sta
producendo è stato possibile rendere
accessibile anche la musica e trovo che
questa cosa debba riempire l'italia di
orgoglio per chi è veramente un grande
passo in avanti molto bello
detto ciò vorrei dire sempre tantissime
cose ma il tempo non c'è quindi sono
costretto a salutarvi e spero che della
nostra chiacchierata possa essere
rimasto qualcosa quando tornate a casa
su cui riflettere e su cui fare alcune
vostre considerazioni
grazie a tutti arrivederci bene gioia è
quello che ci auguriamo proprio nel tema
del cambiamento è che finalmente la
lingua dei segni sia riconosciuta il
nostro intervento finisce qui
e buona serata grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]